[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 15
novembre découvrir des oeuvres des xviie
et xviiie siècle au coeur de la chapelle
royale du château
voilà ce que propose le centre de
musique baroque de versailles
chaque jeudi au chaud les pages et les
chantres du cmbv un soldat vend son âme
au diable contre un livre qui prédit
l'avenir à l'origine de l'histoire du
soldat
igor stravinsky et charles ferdinand
ramuz zh la compagnie une corde à
l'adapt pour sa nouvelle création et les
yvelines seront représentés au
championnat national de breakdance sur
sa une telle hystérie
un jeune chinois nous l'avons rencontrée
elle les feuilles mortes à bicyclette ou
dans les plaines du far west
quelques titres célèbres d'yves montand
le chanteur et comédien disparu en 1991
mais est ce que vous saviez que son nom
de naissance et yves ollivier qu'il a
fui l'italie fasciste et ses parents en
depuis un an une comédie musicale
retrace l'histoire de l'artiste comment
il est devenu yves montand mais aussi
celle du début du xxème siècle un mot
avec christos mitropoulos l'un des
créateurs et comédiens
on trouvait que c'était une histoire
avec ali bougheraba avec qui j'ai écrit
l'histoire
on pensait que c'était plus intéressant
ça nous a plu intéressés de raconter la
partie de sa vie l'ascension comment le
jeune il vole y vivent à venir le
montant la musique accompagne la ville
mon temps et du coup nous l'histoire se
réfère aussi à la musique donc ce n'est
pas forcément que la musique de mon
temps quand à entendre on va entendre
aussi du fred astaire puisqu'il a grandi
avec très vastes aires où des francos
ministres italiens des français
sébastien
[Musique]
on était tous un modèle
ce sont et pour y faire
invisible est de
la télévision tout un symbole pour des
générations celle de nos parents et
grands parents qui ont connu la télé à
tube cathodique est l'arrivée de la
couleur ou les premiers pas de la halle
de l'homme sur la lune
une exposition au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines permet de
redécouvrir à cette époque et questionne
sur notre rapport à la télévision
aujourd'hui camille lambert pour les
plus jeunes ces téléviseurs peuvent
avoir l'air de venir d'un autre monde
des années 50 à aujourd'hui la
télévision a bien changé dans son
contenu et dans sa forme en témoigne
spoutnik ce téléviseurs de philips a
connu son heure de gloire dans les
années 60
c'est un téléviseur qui date de 1969 et
qui est tout à fait emblématique de
l'évolution du poste de télévision dans
les années 60 avec l'apparition de
nouveaux matériaux comme notamment le
plastique qui remplace le bois de la
génération précédente
et puis cette forme tout à fait épuré
futuriste fait dans une simplicité de
2,2 forme
c'est dans les années 70 que les
français s'équipent massivement de ce
nouveau média
le musée de la ville raconte son
histoire dans une exposition
le rôle de la télévision a été
essentielle lors de la création de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines notamment par
l'intermédiaire du crabe et de la bac ce
qu'ils étaient
des associations des structures locales
qui ont permis d'utiliser l'audiovisuel
en particulier l'image télévisuelle
comme outil d'expression la population
vis-à-vis de la construction de 7,8
cette ville nouvelle qui était en train
de se construire un retour nostalgique
au temps où les téléviseurs trôner
fièrement dans les salons
c'est désormais dans nos poches où notre
sac qu'il se décline une nouvelle
génération toujours aussi porté sur les
écrans le château de versailles vous
invite à un voyage dans ses jardins une
exposition penser avec le palais de
tokyo jusqu'au 7 janvier 17 artistes
contemporains exposé dans les brousses
quête du domaine royal
pour cette dixième exposition sculpture
installation sonore oeuvre évolutive
leurs portes c'est dans le bosquet de
l'arc de triomphe que débute le voyage
un 5/6 trône celui de marguerite humeau
l'une des dix sept artistes qui
composent ce voyage d'hiver ce récit
suit les mouvements des saisons les
mouvements de la nature auquel le
château de versailles est identifié
s'est toujours montré que la création
naturellement a toute sa place au
château de versailles et qu' elle n'est
en aucun cas en opposition avec le
patrimoine mais contre contraire le
présent et le passé se servent de me
revoir réciproque
c'est merveilleux de travailler sur le
changement de la saison et d'en faire un
symbole qui était très conscient chez
les artistes qui ont conçu le parc de
versailles
c'est l'équivalent centre un état
intérieur et un état de la nature il
fallait montrer ce qu'était la culture
compte la sculpture contemporaine dans
la diversité de ses matériaux ses
installations donc on a choisi les
meilleurs artistes de générations
diverses de pays divers
une progression émotionnelle où se
mêlent la solitude mélancolique d'une
tête
esseulé celle pensé par l'artiste
néerlandais marke wenders à la sculpture
paradoxal et fragile de david altmejd
j'aime quand les choses sont pas
iger dans un moment mais plutôt qu'elle
donne l'impression qu'ils sont tout le
temps en transformation continuelle j'ai
pris la décision de pas l'inquiéter
justement avec ne pas faire une
sculpture de bronze parce que c'est
c'est la chose la plus évidente quand on
présente une sculpture à l'extérieur
bronze tout ça mais plutôt de faire
quelque chose de complètement inattendu
et d'utiliser des matériaux super
fragile
les matériaux mixtes colorés des oeuvres
parfois évolutif dans le temps des
créations monumentales pour voir le
temps d'un hiver les jardins d'un
domaine magistrale d'un autre oeil
titelouze lully ou encore marc antoine
charpentier sont au programme des jeudis
musicaux chaque semaine les 40 chanteurs
du centre de musique baroque de
versailles se produisent à la chapelle
royale du château de versailles pour en
parler avec nous donne escrocs balla
administrateur de la maîtrise les pages
et les chambres bonjour alors les jeudis
musicaux ont débuté la semaine dernière
le 9 novembre et pour cette saison
2017-2018 il ya vingt-quatre concerts de
programmer voilà exactement c'est un
concert que l'on propose toutes les
semaines de début novembre début juin le
jeudi à 17 heures 30 à la chapelle
royale quitte à un écrin absolument sont
eux pour écouter de la musique ainsi la
chapelle tels que la pensée voulu louis
xiv et qui a été inaugurée en 1710 est
donc dans cette acoustique
extraordinaire on propose un concert de
musique baroque
toutes les semaines et la chapelle
royale c'est un lieu qui se faisait de
soi en groupe mais quand on est en
visite les beaux châteaux
on ne fait qu'y passer on peut pas
entrer à l'intérieur ça c'est moyen de
découvrir autrement le lieu exactement
tout à fait parce que c'est un lieu dont
richesse architecturale du programme
également deux fresques de peinture est
absolument extraordinaire et donc avoir
la chance d'entendre les musiques ont
été composées pensé conçu pour ce lieu
dans le lieu même est une blague quelque
chose d'assez extraordinaire pour
l'ensemble du public chaque semaine et
au chant 40 chanteurs les pages et les
chantres oui bien sûr alors en fait ce
coeur qu'on a reconstitué donc au centre
de musique baroque de versailles ya de
cela maintenant plus de 25 ans est une
évocation en fait du choeur de la
chapelle royale sous louis xiv qui était
un choeur composé d'enfants qui
chantaient les parties les plus aigus
les parties de dessus et ensuite de voix
d'hommes qui chantait voilà toutes les
parties des tessitures masculine est
aujourd'hui ce choeur il est composé
d'une part donc d'enfants les pages qui
sont des élèves en classes à horaires
aménagés qui sont tout d'abord en classe
en primaire à l'école va plaire à
versailles et ensuite au collège rameau
et puis les adultes eux ce sont des
jeunes chanteurs professionnels qui se
destinent à une spécialisation en
répertoire baroque et qui vont passer
chez nous de deux à trois années de
formation à temps plein au sein du cmbv
ont pour les plus jeunes les pages à ses
concerts les jeudis musicaux c'est aussi
un premier pas face au public
absolument c'est une expérience
extraordinaire de pouvoir chaque semaine
quasiment se présentait comme cela en
public aussi bien en tant que choriste
comme soliste d'ailleurs parce qu' un
certain nombre développent des capacités
vocales qui leur permettent déjà de
chanter en soliste et c'est cette
expérience qu'on partage avec le public
chaque semaine à tout à l'heure j'ai
donné trois noms de compositeur
qu'est-ce qu'on chante la musique
baroque ses 17e et 18e siècles
quels sont les grands compositeurs alors
bien sûr il ya beaucoup de compositeurs
très connus qu'on va retrouver tout au
long de l'année comme
li charpentier mais l'objectif du centre
de musique baroque de versailles c'est
aussi de mettre en oeuvre tout ce
travail de recherche auprès de
compositeurs qui sont complètement tombé
dans l'oubli depuis xviie et xviiie
siècles et par exemple cette année on va
donner au château de versailles
des compositeurs comme philippe
d'orléans le régent qui lui même donc
s'était formé à l'écriture de la musique
et a écrit une tragédie lyrique qu'on va
donner pour un certain nombre des
extraits en avril prochain
je pourrais citer encore pierre louis
polio donc on a complètement oublié
aujourd'hui
eh bien c'était le maître de chapelle de
la cathédrale de beauvais et il a écrit
des mots t'es absolument somptueux au
mitan du xviiie siècle à peu près et là
on les fera redécouvrir en février
prochain en collaboration avec le
conservatoire de paris et le cnrs donc
en fait des oeuvres qui ont maintenant
trois cents ans les musicologues donc
les chercheurs du centre de musique
baroque de versailles où les chercheurs
associés avec lesquels on travaille dans
d'autres institutions continuent de
faire l'état des archives disponibles en
france et à l'étranger et de retrouver
régulièrement des oeuvres que l'on
pensait avoir perdu et par exemple la
semaine dernière on a redonné une messe
polyphonique de gentils toulouse qui
était maître de chapelle à la cathédrale
de rouen au début du xviie siècle et
cette messe qui a été édité en 726 eh
bien on l'a retrouvé en 2016 voilà donc
ce sont de vrais inédits en l'occurrence
alors on disait il ya vingt-quatre dates
jusqu'en juin ehrhart et mais toutes ne
sont pas assurées par le cmb par la
maîtrise qu est-ce que vous avez des
partenaires et notamment demain le 16
novembre il y aura les intermèdes de
monsieur de lully et ce sera les
conservatoires à rayonnement régional de
paris et de versailles et celui
départemental de paris saclay exactement
donc un certain nombre de dates ne
peuvent pas être assurée par les pages
et les chantres même parce que nous
avons aussi des productions
professionnelles à mettre en oeuvre et
social que ce sera le cas d'ailleurs
samedi prochain à la chapelle royale
donc je dis là l'audition va être
assurée par les conservatoires de paris
de versailles et d'orsay pour un
programme orchestrale avec les 24
violons du roy ce sont des instruments
que l'on a fait reconstruire au centre
de musique baroque de versailles et sous
la direction du violoniste patrick cohën
akenine et bien les dires les étudiants
de ces trois conservatoires vont
interpréter des suites orchestrales de
lully extraites de psyché et des amants
magnifiques
il ya un côté pratique qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'il faut qu'il faut noter
c'est que c'est entièrement gratuit
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas le prix du
billet de loterie du château exactement
c'est une chance vraiment pour le public
chaque semaine nous avons entre 400 et
500 spectateurs qui viennent assister à
ces concerts gratuitement
donc on se présente à l'entrée du
château à partir de 17h on ne s'acquitte
pas donc d'un billet de visiteurs et on
rentre directement dans la chapelle
royale pour assister à un concert qui va
durer entre une heure et une heure et
quart avec soin le coeur ou des
ensembles instrumentaux et puis on a
aucun l'occasion également chaque jeudi
d'entendre le grand orgue clicquot qui
est joué par un étudiant du cnsm de
paris ont des rendez vous à ne pas
manquer il y en a 24 est toujours
l'occasion d'en voir au moins un merci
de l'escroc bas nations les jeudis
musicaux c'est donc tous les jeudis à 17
heures 30 à la chapelle royale
on reste à versailles avec là aussi un
cancer c'est le premier de l'association
art corps et âme
elle a été fondée par la pianiste
versaillaise christine généraux ce
samedi 18 novembre les artères les
artistes interpréteront notamment
mendelssohn et rachmaninoff il a
seulement 15 ans et il évolue un niveau
national qu élise viry un jeune vie
sinois participe au championnat national
de breakdance marlène iapichino et
nicolas d'andré nous rencontrer pour
nous des étirements de la concentration
et des prises de notes à l'âge de 15 ans
kelis prend ses entraînements au sérieux
l'enjeu est de taille il est qualifié
pour le championnat de france de break
dance
alors pour être prêt la stratégie bien
rodée au début de l'entraînement je mets
mes sont à moi que j'ai dans ma playlist
je mets au hasard et en fait après au
milieu de l'entraînement je vais sur
youtube et je mets des sons que je
connais pas pour que je puisse
m'habituer à danser sur différents
styles de fond parce que ça va pas
toujours être le même son cette
discipline il la partage avec toute sa
famille quand les coaches ne sont pas là
ce sont ses frères des soeurs eux-mêmes
break dancer qui corrige ses gestes avec
une grande publicité
c'est vrai qu'on nous dit souvent qu'on
est lié on a souvent des des codes pour
se motiver et puis ne training ils sont
faut savoir qu'ils sont jamais vraiment
vraiment sérieux en général on fait
toujours un peu les qu'on en fait on est
lié et c'est ça qui nous rend qui fait
un peu notre phare à ce budget
en sportif accompli kelis troc parfois
les baskets de break dance pour les
crampons il évolue comme milieu droit
dans l'équipe de voisins-le-bretonneux
depuis septembre c'est vraiment un sport
qui me plaisent j'aime bien la vitesse
tout ce qui est jeu technique et ce que
j'aime surtout c'est d'esprit d'équipé
surtout quand on va le mieux une fois
encore kelis n'est pas seule sa famille
est au bord du terrain pour l'encourager
on laisse vraiment tout le temps au
quotidien après on lui permet aussi de
se détendre un peu à côté de pas que
penser à ça parce que après sinon ça
fonctionne pas donc on est vraiment là
au quotidien peu importe ce qu'il ya
quoi
rendez vous le 18 novembre sur la piste
de danse de liévin dans le pas de calais
pour les championnats de france de
breakdance kelis blessé l'année dernière
a hâte d'affronter ses adversaires
on poursuit ce magazine avec nos deux
nouveaux invités un peu de musique un
peu de théâtre un mélange autour
d'histoires du soldat qui se joue
actuellement à la batterie de guyancourt
c'est un hors les murs de la ferme de
bel ébat de guyancourt une version est
proposée par la compagnie une corde avec
votre foi ces gars là vous êtes metteur
en scène vous fait le récit de cette
création
bonsoir et les solistes de versailles
dont vous faites parti marielle le money
vous êtes pianiste oui alors histoire du
soldat c'est un quatuor sur scène pour
raconter l'histoire de joseph un soldat
qui vend son âme au diable
est ce que c'est ça il ya une erreur non
non si ça si on veut dire un quatuor
après c'est entre comédiens musiciens
voilà trois trois musiciens
et donc un comédien un récitant pour
raconter cette histoire qui à l'origine
avait été composée pour qui est composé
pour sept musiciens et quatre comédiens
alors comment ça s'adapte justement vous
avez réduit la taille déjà des comédiens
des musiciens aussi vous avez dû
réapproprie réécrire peut-être des
partitions vous réadapter le texte ne
deux mois sur le texte
sur la musique je serais incapable de
quoi que ce soit mais non sur le sur le
sur le texte il ya peut-être à
contrecoeur une une partie que
qu'on n'a pas reprise du texte de ramuz
encore à vraiment à contrecoeur mais
sinon la durée du spectacle est quasi la
même case identité bien sûr et en
musique alors passé de 7 à 3 réécoutez
au départ donc c était écrit
effectivement pour sept musiciens donc
c'est vraiment un ensemble qui se
rapproche plutôt d'un ensemble de jazz
plutôt qu'un ensemble classique
et finalement il n'y a pas de piano dans
la version originale mais le piano
apporte une des couleurs nouvelles des
attaques nouvelles et peu exprimé
beaucoup de choses aussi et notamment la
percussion donc maintenant la version
trio s'adapte ça bastia fait oui alors
c'est une oeuvre composée par igor
stravinsky en 1917 sur un texte de
charles ferdinand ramuz êtes vous le
souhaitez vous avez choisi ce texte là
pourquoi histoire du soldat
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose de
commun et c'est vrai que je pense qu'on
pourrait tous le dire il se trouve que
bon voilà c'est peu et c'est une
histoire que moi je connais depuis que
je suis enfant
que j'ai toujours écouté au même titre
peut-être que babar que le carnaval des
animaux
c'est quelque chose qui est
contrairement d'ailleurs à d'autres
oeuvres finalement l'histoire du soldat
elle en tout cas elle m'a accompagné
elle m'a accompagné toute ma vie enfin
je pense que c'est quand on découvre
qu'en découvre stravinsky re amusera mu
a eu une influence parce que moi je vais
parler peut-être du côté littérature -
du côté musical mais il a une influence
majeure
c'est à dire que je vois les poètes sur
lequel il m'a amené finalement cette
oreille jeunes
quand j'étais enfant et que je
l'écoutais sama
ça m'a fait comprendre la littérature ça
m'a fait où ça m'a ouvert après très
très rapidement à des poètes comme norge
prévert et puis le sens finalement du
rythme dans le mouv qui aimait chaire
amusé juste hallucinant c'est à dire que
la musique dans le verbe est peut-être
plus importante finalement que ce
qu'elle raconte ajustements je vous
propose qu'on ne regarde un extrait
c'est une médaille en argent doré avec
saint joseph son patron dessus elles ont
tant mieux
enfin toujours fuyant cent des papiers
avec des choses dedans des cartouches
sur un miroir tout juste si on peut s'y
voir
c'est un spectacle musical à voir dès 8
ans ça s'adapte bien aux enfants
musicalement c'est extraordinaire parce
que c'est une musique extrêmement
spontanée qui est peut-être comme disait
godefroy tout à l'heure peut-être même
plus accessible pour des enfants de huit
ans que qu'elle et écouter du mozart par
exemple parce que c'est une musique qui
n'a qui n'a pas de transition qui est
brute et qui a une énergie rythmique
considérable et pour les enfants ces
épices à sa touche vraiment l'aspect le
plus même primitif de l'être humain et
et les enfants ils sont très sensibles
que l'on peut au contraire qu'un au
contraire c'est ce qui caractérise
souvent stravinsky on connaît surtout le
sacre du printemps
oui donc finalement voilà c'est rythme
attache l'enfant accroche et ça repart
sur le texte comment vous avez fait là
la jonction entre les deux comment ça se
travaille déjà si je peux me permettre
ce n'est même pas c'est tellement bien
écrit et tellement une osmose entre le
texte et la musique c'est à dire que le
le théâtre fait partie du concert et le
concert fait partie du théâtre le
comédien d'ailleurs godefroy qui est un
comédien exceptionnel n'est pas
seulement comédien il est aussi musicien
parce que comme tu le disais tout à
l'heure il ya toute cette musique et le
la couleur des sens qui est bien plus
important parfois une que le sens et la
musique parfois décrit elle est
descriptive mais parfois aussi elle
raconte une histoire
par exemple il ya le passage du soldat
qui vint guérir la princesse c'est
vraiment la musique qui va d'art et
finalement ce passage merci à tous les
deux alors pour découvrir ce qui arrive
à joseph
rendez vous à 15 heures ce samedi à la
batterie de guyancourt
[Musique]
cette semaine c'est du beau quand dû
signer cette d'elancourt qui vous
donnent rendez vous écouter alors le
coup de coeur du si 17 cette semaine
c'est évidemment la troisième édition du
festival saint quentin avec quatre
événements aussi 17 vendredi soir ce
qu'il faut de silence un documentaire
sur la genèse on va dire d'un opéra
entrée libre samedi à 18h30 on aura le
plaisir de recevoir youssef qui a fait
l'objet d'un film réalisé par un
réalisateur et une amende qui sera aussi
présent youssef legrand brille donc qui
viendra aussi jouer de son instrument
artisanal fabriqué chez lui avec les
moyens du bord dimanche matin à 10h30 la
petite musique des bruits si des filous
pour les tout-petits autour de la
musique donc le thème du festival et
l'après midi entrée libre aussi
réservations au 01 30 51 03 02 la
clôture du festival à partir de 16
heures en partenariat avec l'école de
musique qu'il jouera des morceaux de
musique de films dans la salle ensuite
la projection du documentaire sur pierre
barou et la remise des prix du festival
tous a suivi par un petit cocktail voilà
j'espère à cette semaine dans les salles
le festival 50 ans se déroule sur tout
le septième territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines jusqu'au dimanche 19 demande
plusieurs jours de projections qui se
termineront pas une remise des prix
l'ubo qu on vous en a parlé mais le
point on le fait que tirer bat rodez le
directeur de tv 78 champion du
documentaire déjà tv 60 vite qu'au
produit beaucoup documentaire sur la
musique notamment un qui sera diffusée
en clôture sur pierre barouh qu'un très
beau documentaire qui a eu le prix sacem
c'est un festival il ya des gagnants il
y en aura quatre cette année donc il ya
toujours le prix des cinémas le prix
troisième le prix tb 78 et cette année
il ya le prix du public prix spécial du
public voilà et on peut voter sur le
site internet saint-quentin point fr et
tous les documentaires peuvent être
choisies par par les téléspectateurs et
les spectateurs
les internautes
au début de cet agenda avec une soirée
placée sous le signe du rire au scarabée
de la verrière steph est en pleine forme
et elle vous invite au carré pour une
soirée music-hall des airs jazzy une
bonne dose d'ironie regarder je me
trouvais iloveyou paye pays
et vous seriez restés bouche bée
j'aurais arraché ma fourrure là vous
seriez parti csu sinon pour toi le
boulot ça va intermittente moi je
courais pas t'as pas tentés de laisser
tomber
prendre un travail tue c'est un vrai à
la pêche aux petits oignons maman
d'apprendre pognon la merise de trappes
ouvre sa scène aux musiciens amateurs et
confirmés ce samedi c'est la troisième
édition de fait des groupes un tremplin
musical à la fin du concert le public et
le jury
votre impôt son groupe préféré et le
vainqueur sera programmée lors de la
fête de la ville au prisme c'est le
cirque qui est à l'honneur avec la
première création du cirque le roux un
mélange de huis clos de cabaret de
cirque dans les années 30 avec des
causes acrobaties de haut niveau
regarder
m
à
on
au théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines vous pourrez écouter les
orchestres philharmonique de radio
france 3 compositeurs sont à l'honneur
luigi nono gérard pesson et claude
debussy et en termine au rendez vous
culturel avec une conférence un peu
particulière c'est au château de
rambouillet et vous pourrez échanger et
assister un défilé sur l'histoire du
costume au xviiie siècle le statut de
culture est maintenant terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi le magazine
est à revoir sur notre site internet
notre application mobile à mercredi
prochain
[Musique]